-Now, I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
#MyWeirdTeacher stories
from you guys.
Here we go. The first one is
from @Steve-Shu.
He says, "The day after
we turned in drafts
of our term papers,
the professor wore all black
to signify his
disappointment in our work."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-He had to tell them, too.
Wouldn't figure that
one out for yourself.
-I'm mourning the loss
of your grades, yeah.
This one is from @JonBalun.
He said, "My teacher moved
his left hand in circles
as he erased the board
with his right hand
so he would build
the muscles evenly."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wax on, wax off.
-Miyagi.
Miyagi, yeah.
This one is from @tinagibala.
She says, "My homeroom teacher
kept a list on the chalkboard
of people who needed
prom dates."
-Aw.
[ Audience aws ]
[ Applause ]
Oh.
Tina?
You and Gary.
-Derek's been up here for --
[ Light laughter ]
For three weeks now.
So anyone wants -- Anyone.
You know anyone who wants
to go with Derek, or any --
Do you have any pets at home
that could maybe go with Derek?
Just so he doesn't go alone.
This one is from @leighlo-maria.
She said, "My biology teacher
handed us back
our graded homework.
Every paper was maroon.
She apparently spilled
a bottle of red wine."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yoinks!
[ Pop ]
-This one's from @Corcorcoran2.
He says, "If it was your
birthday, my teacher would draw
a cake on the board and ask you
to blow out the candles.
You just had to stand there
and blow on the chalkboard
until he said
the candles went out."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Not yet!
-Not yet!
-Not yet, keep going.
[ Laughs ]
-Not yet!
-[ Fake crying ]
-Okay. Oh, they're trick
candles, they're back on again.
What's your problem, dude?
-I'm in charge!
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
I'm the boss, get it?
This one's from @HBP-ALWAYS98.
She says, "Whenever I ask my
teacher what we're doing today,
she says, 'working hard
and suffering greatly,
because life is pain.'"
-Oh.
[ Applause ]
Wow!
-[ Laughs ]
This one's from @mac-ken-cheese.
-Oh, nice.
-I get it.
Not bad.
Mac n' cheese.
-Mac n' cheese.
-Mac Ken Cheese.
-Nice one.
-That's a nice one.
-Yeah.
-mac-ken-cheese.
She says, "My chemistry teacher
had a taxidermied armadillo
in the classroom.
For a while, it wore a party hat
and it was called
The Partydillo."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah!
-Whoop whoop whoop!
-Partydillo!
-Byeh, byeh, byeh, byeh!
-Raise the roof, Derek!
[ Laughter ]
-The armadillo said that?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-This is from @RaskolnikovsAxe.
-Ooh, deep.
[ Light laughter ]
A little crime and punishment.
Derek.
[ Light laughter ]
-He says, "At the end
of a test period,
our science teacher would
respond to our
'one more sec, one more sec!'
with 'no more secs!'"
[ Laughter ]
"No more secs
in this classroom!"
[ Applause ]
I'm talking to you, Derek.
-Yeah.
This last one's
from @TheDonald-Stump.
[ Light laughter ]
He says, "My teacher would tell
us to work hard in math
and science classes,
otherwise we'd end up
as a gym teacher.
He was also the gym teacher."
-Oh!
-There you go.
There are your
"Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out more
of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.